for the sentencing for the man who  killed five cyclists north of  searchlight in december started this  afternoon  jordan barson is facing up to 40 years  in jail  he pled guilty to two counts of dui  resulting in death  when the box truck he was driving  crashed into the group  barson apologized to the family of the  victims family members of those victims  shared emotional statements about  how the tragedy has impacted their lives  they urged the judge to give barton the  maximum sentence of 40 years in jail  sentencing will resume tomorrow  afternoon joe muller was  at the courthouse today he will have  more on what happened on later editions  of eight news now at five  and six o'clock